all right this is super serious and so
we're not going to make light of this uh
Lauren bobert the radical and repugnant
sanctimonious
Republican congresswoman who talks about
how Christianity is the one moral path
and Christianity needs to be involved in
civil government and all these different
how everybody else is a bad parent if
they have a a trans kid or if they're
gay or whatever okay that Lauren bobert
was potentially involved in covering up
her own then husband soon to be
ex-husbands alleged
child abuse
against one of her own kids
there is
the story of the facts and there is the
story of Lauren bobert's I know with
Rhonda sanctimonious it sounds crazy to
use the word but her sanctimonious
pleading about how she is the moral one
when she may have been involved in this
so let me tell you what the allegations
are
in December Lauren bobert's teen son
called 9-1-1
and the reason that her son called 9-1-1
was to report that his dad Lauren
bobert's husband was abusing him that he
was quote throwing me in the house
the teens sobbed through the two-minute
call saying he didn't understand why his
dad was mad
the boy called back soon after
suddenly denying it happened with Lauren
bobert jumping on the call to say the
boy is fine
okay so two minute phone call
the teen calls and says my dad's
throwing me around I don't know why the
call ends Garfield County Sheriff's
Office deputies are going out to Lauren
bobert's house the teen calls back and
says oh I take it back and suddenly
Lauren bobert's on the phone and says my
son doesn't need any help
Jason bober denied to the deputies that
he got physical with his son
put out Lauren bobert put out a
statement yesterday saying the safety
and well-being of my family are the most
important things in the world we've had
tough times and heartache I've taken
action to ensure there are better days
ahead presumably meaning that she is
going to be divorcing her husband an
affidavit says that when Jason bobert
was served with the petition for divorce
he became extremely angry
he started yelling and using profanity
and he uh Lauren bobert denied that
that's what happened
when we go back to 2004 we know that
Jason bobert was arrested and pleaded
guilty to public indecency and lewd
exposure after allegedly exposing his
genitals to two young women one of whom
was 16 years old at a bowling alley
Lauren bobert defends her husband in her
book claiming that he was actually the
one who was harassed by a female
bartender who said show me your genitals
so we have a situation here where if it
is true
it appears as though Lauren bobert
potentially realizing
the very bad situation that it would be
for her
for police to show up at her house just
a few months ago
potentially to arrest her husband for
child abuse that her son called 9-1-1
and said was going on
the speculation is she made her son call
and retract that allegation
that his dad bobert's husband
was becoming physically violent and if
that is the case she would be involved
in a cover-up of child abuse now we
don't know that that is what took place
we are still learning more about this
but it's not about getting involved in
the personal lives of these individuals
beyond the fact that they want to they
both declare themselves the top and
mightiest Arbiters of morality and
ethics
and they go around telling everybody
else what they're doing wrong based on
sexual identity or gender or whatever
the case may be
and in addition to that that they stake
a claim for their religion which in this
you know with Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bober and others it's always
Christianity that Christianity is the
moral and ethical law of the land that
should be the law of civil government so
they are sanctimonious Hypocrites now
whatever the truth is about whatever
abuse
one of Lauren bobert's Sons may have
suffered it's a law enforcement matter
but to the extent that these folks want
to make law and tell everybody else
what's right and what's wrong they are
horrible sanctimonious Hypocrites Mike
Pence is going to have a CNN Town Hall
but he's not a candidate for the
presidency so what on Earth is going on
let's see if we can figure it out CNN
has announced that on June 7th there
will be a Republican Presidential town
hall with vice president Mike Pence
what what you're going to do a town hall
with a guy who's not a candidate what on
Earth is going on and it even says that
Pence is going to take questions from
Iowa Republicans and Iowa voters who
will be participating in the Republican
caucuses but he hasn't said he's running
well there is a KCCI uh Yahoo life Yahoo
news report we never know who's
reporting this former vice president
Mike Pence lays the groundwork for a
2024 presidential run in Des Moines in
Des Moines
it is increasingly looking like former
vice president Mike Pence is going to be
running against the guy he served under
Donald Trump which is stunning now is it
unprecedented no there are a couple
other examples of Vice Presidents
running against the president they
served under I don't have them in front
of me but we're gonna if Pence becomes a
candidate we will look at that in more
detail if you thought that this primary
was going to get ugly with the entrance
of Ron DeSantis against Donald Trump and
it is already getting very ugly because
of that just you wait until Mike Pence
gets in now interestingly Mike Pence is
in third place right now right now the
Trump decline since the DeSantis
announcement continues the DeSantis bump
since the announcement continues Trump
down to 54 descent this up to 21 but
Mike Pence is basically tied with Nikki
Haley just under five percent
now does Mike Pence really have a shot
at becoming the Republican nominee I
don't believe so but to the extent that
Trump gets triggered by so-called
disloyalty you can imagine no more
disloyal action from your own former
vice president
then that vice president saying I
actually think I would be so much better
for the country than you even though I
served alongside you that I am going to
run against you so this is going to be
listen the set the town hall is going to
be Mike Pence not exactly electrifying
the crowd uh Mike Pence lacking Charisma
almost as acutely as Ron DeSantis and
the event itself is not really something
that I'm super interested in but but the
fact that it's sort of an event for a
presidential candidate even though he's
not actually a presidential candidate
really points to a fascinating situation
that we will be following
extraordinarily closely that's June 7th
Mike Pence I guess looking like he's
gonna run against Trump just wait
till you see Trump fly off the handle
major news from the Maga riots Stuart
Rhodes the founder of the right wing
Oath Keepers group has been sentenced to
18 years in prison for his role in
seditious conspiracy surrounding the
January 6th Maga riots this is a serious
sentence the NBC news report reads the
founder of The far-right Oath Keepers
has been sentenced to 18 years in
federal prison in connection with the
January 6th attack on the capitol
following his conviction on seditious
conspiracy the sentence for Stuart
Rhodes is the longest imposed on a
January 6th defendant to date in a
politically charged courtroom before
sentencing Rhodes called himself a
political prisoner and said when he
talked about regime change in a phone
call with supporters earlier this week
he meant he hopes that Trump will win in
2024.
the judge disagreed and says you sir
present an ongoing threat and apparel to
this country and to the Republic and to
the very fabric of this democracy
um
wow so I want to say a couple of things
about this
one of the things I don't do unlike the
right which says lock this person up
lock that person up throw away the key
death penalty all these different things
I have not once said
I want them to crush these rioters and
throw them in prison for life or
whatever what I have said is we have
evidence that crimes were committed
so folks should be charged and then they
should go through the legal process and
if they are convicted they should be
sentenced fairly in according to
sentencing guidelines for the crimes for
which they are convicted that's Law and
Order and all of these right Wingers who
want to shout that they are for Law and
Order while they demand Hillary be
locked up and they demand that Biden be
locked up and Hunter Biden all this
stuff you're not actually for Law and
Order if you want to deny people uh due
process and so all along I have said
there are very serious allegations
surrounding many of these Trump rioters
but I want Justice to be done and that
means that I'm not going to go around
demanding people be locked up
at all or for amounts of time that don't
correspond to the crimes they have
committed here we have a situation where
Stuart Rhodes was found guilty of
seditious conspiracy that's a very
serious crime there are those who will
say the pro the mere prosecution of
these individuals is politically
motivated or all these are the judges
remember a lot of these judges or Trump
appointees if you actually can
demonstrate that there was wrongdoing or
mishandling of these cases do it they
all get their right to appeal but we are
now seeing
that these are serious crimes which
juries of these individuals peers
have decided there is enough evidence to
convict so now Stuart Rhodes is facing
uh eight facing he's been sentenced to
18 years I always forget whether there
are any situations with Federal
sentences where you get time off for for
good behavior maybe he will serve close
to that full 18 maybe he will not uh
this is a reminder
hopefully even though there have not
been consequences to the the top level
insiders like Trump and we'll see if
there are any consequences this is a
reminder that you might want to allow
peaceful transitions of power to take
place rather than doing what these
criminals and we can say now that they
are criminals have done all right so
we'll see if there are any longer
sentences but to date 18 years the
longest coming out of the Maga riots
Monday Memorial Day folks we're off on
Monday for Memorial Day but remember
we'll be doing our one day membership
special get notified by getting on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
the David pakman show is an audience
meaning you funded program we depend on
the support of viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast or
watch us on YouTube or Tick Tock or
wherever the case may be
to sign up for membership at
joinpakman.com it's an incredible thing
you can do so using the coupon code 24
starts now and we are really in the
thick of it as many of you know you can
also instead wait until Monday this
Monday Memorial Day get on my newsletter
at davidpackman.com and Monday you'll
get an email telling you how to sign up
at an even more outrageous discount
let's go to everyone's favorite or least
favorite part of the week nobody is in
the middle on these uh hearing from the
audience segments people either love it
or they hate it and they threaten to
leave all the time I want to hear from
some of the most important people to us
the viewers because otherwise I'm a guy
in a room with a microphone and some
lights and it would be really sad we
take calls on Fridays via Discord you
can find the Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord let's start today with Mark from
San Antonio Texas Mark welcome to the
program what can I do for you today
am I unmuted you are unmuted and coming
through loud and clear sir
great uh thanks for taking my call again
David
um I'm I don't know if you saw yesterday
but uh Carey Lake again had her lawsuit
tossed out and I'm just starting to
think more and more that unlike you know
Marjory Taylor green and and
Mike pillow I don't think she's a firm
believer I think she's just nothing but
a grift and I wanted your take on it
with with each subsequent you know uh
appearance she makes on media it just
seems more and more like she's just a
really polished news person that's
giving you know a polished performance
uh however horrifying that might be I
tend to agree with you and one of the
comments I made earlier this week was
if she had been unable to grift any
money with this stuff starting in
November she would have stopped by now
the reason that it continues is people
keep donating and now even though it's
it's being called the last ditch that
was now thrown out
she's now saying she's going to try to
get it to the Supreme Court and she even
said you can still keep donating even
though I'm not here asking for money you
can keep donating I believe that with
Carrie Lake it is a grift I don't think
she believes any of it for a second she
knows Katie Hobbs won maybe she believes
some element of how the election was run
was unfair but the idea that she's
continuing to fight to be made to the
governor it's like that's not how it
works it's not going to happen I agree
with you that Carrie lake is a grifter
yeah it's just it's it's performance art
at this point and I think you know if if
somebody uh on the left were willing to
you know go that far to create a
performance you know a character and
then suddenly flip the script and oh by
the way I'm Progressive I think you know
the right wing meter would absolutely
explode but here they've just platformed
her for forever uh when I I'm sure she's
probably somewhere in the middle or
moderately conservative but this is you
know it's just Insanity it's performance
yeah I remember like I don't want to
misspeak but didn't she support Obama at
one point
yes yeah that's uh security Lake
supported Obama uh yeah Obama backing
Arizona news anchor became a Maga
darling yep well it is what it is listen
how's that San Antonio Riverwalk I've
never been
you know um it used to be just firmly
for tourists and then you know there was
a bunch of money committed to extending
the the River Reach and there's only
like one last section left but you'll be
able to go from the museums
um all the way to the very
um tip you know very southern tip of it
to the the final mission the UNESCO
Mission Heritage sites so you know sure
the Riverwalk downtown is just nothing
but restaurants and hotels but once you
get outside of that you can rent a bike
and ride all the way to the to the
Spanish missions and it's it's a good
time it's it's really pretty I'm gonna
have to get down there Mark I appreciate
the call
all right thanks David all right there
it goes mark from San Antonio Texas why
don't we go next
to Bentley from Utah Bentley welcome to
the program
hello can you hear me yes I can
all right perfect
um so I've just been looking into some
other countries like Denmark lately and
I was wondering if you would ever
consider moving to a country that is
more like
socially Democratic you know listen I
would consider it the the thing for me
about uh you know Denmark would be an
easy one to go I speak English and
Spanish and Denmark would be easy
because everybody speaks English in
Denmark or most people do I've been
there it's a fantastic country the
cuisine was great the people were
delightful expensive expensive country
for sure in really practical terms I'm
not seriously considering moving other
than I would and I plan to especially
for my daughter to get Spanish Immersion
I do plan to spend extended periods of
time in Argentina and I've actually done
so recently like with not not with big
Fanfare but there have been periods
where I've produced the show from
Argentina
um but moving you know
circumstances would have to be very
extenuating for me to move because the
reality is a bunch of my family is in
the United States my job is in the
United States a lot of my friends and
you know this sort of thing so Denmark
is a place if if I were looking to move
Denmark would be a great place to move
to I'm just not actively looking right
now
yeah fair enough thanks for taking my
call all right Bentley from Utah great
to hear from you very much appreciate
that let's go to uh is it Phineas let's
go to Phineas from is it Kentucky
something with a K I'm not sure
Phineas please unmute yourself so we can
hear what your name is and where you go
oh Kansas Phineas from Kansas yes sorry
uh Phineas from Kansas hi David thanks
for having me on I was calling to ask in
2010 the Supreme Court overturned
Citizens United and if you look at voter
participation before 2010 it actually
shows a decrease in in voter
participation and volume and numbers
um and ever since then we've seen a
growth in these numbers I was just
wondering if you believe that as opposed
to
supporting a party The increased
spending in elections has merely just
increased voter participation which
could potentially backbite against
Republicans and have an advantage for
Democrats well hold on a second you said
in 2010 the Supreme Court overturned
citizens united that's a that's a the
phrasing is is relevant here because my
understanding is I'm sorry in 2010 yeah
the Supreme Court okay in 2010 the
Supreme Court
reversed an earlier decision by a lower
court which upheld that the first
amendment applies to campaign Finance
laws and uncapped a lot of different
types of spending we're on the same page
on that right
yes yeah you're arguing that after that
happened
we've actually seen voter participation
increase which isn't good for
Republicans so it sounds like what
you're saying is in some underhanded way
might the citizens united decision of
2010 actually have been a bad thing for
Republicans am I understanding correctly
that is correct I think the difficulty
of that argument is that correlation is
different than causation we would have
to demonstrate that political turnout
increased because of that decision and
I've not seen any evidence that that's
the case
okay well I appreciate your time thank
you all right Phineas from Kansas a
perfectly reasonable question I must say
let's go next to Connor from New Jersey
Connor from New Jersey welcome to the
program what's on your mind oh well uh
hey David I've talked to you a couple
times already appreciate you having me
on the show again I love it
um so I remember I called you a while
back
um I saw the video you did where we did
like a snippet of our conversation where
I really didn't elaborate on what was
going on about with me coming from a
conservative space but again last time
was for me to say thank you for what you
do and you know I really find you
inspiring but let's move on from that
please um let's try to address like
where I'm coming from in like this weird
mix where I see myself as like socially
conservative and politically Progressive
right so I explained to you that like
I'm for gay marriage I support the idea
of LGBT rights and you know that we
should be able to see humans as humans
and not say like oh you're living a
delusion people should be able to at
least live their lives to the fullest
capabilities
so where I think that I might lean more
towards like uh or right leaning take is
I'm for a free market to a degree right
I like the idea of small businesses
being able to freely compete amongst one
another but where I might be more
Progressive is where it comes to
corporations I feel like for them to
operate in a free market leads to small
businesses not being able to operate
freely as they would want to be in my
issue with corporations operating freely
is they have a tendency to smush any
ability for small businesses to really
freely operate and my argument for this
is like let's say you had this small
non-paw shop those shops went away when
something like Walmart came in which had
much further stock had the ability to
out compete in terms of
products that they could sell they had a
much larger net worth than these small
businesses and a lot of them would end
up being bought up
because they just would perceive the
money and be like well why am I going to
continue to struggle against Walmart if
I'm getting this money I I just Connor
I'm not sure I really understand
so you're saying on the one hand let me
see if I can understand the positions
you've outlined you you told me your
left wing on gay marriage and you are
progressive on corporations to the
extent that larger companies uh scoop up
or put out of business mom and pops but
you're generally speaking for a free
market and low business regulation which
makes you economically right-wing my
understanding the position is correct
yeah so I want the smaller businesses to
be able to operate more freely but I
think larger corporations should be
regulated to prevent them from corporate
monopolies being able to do things like
abuse offshore workers
um I mean a fine example would be in the
technological Industries we use
in the US I've learned it's not the same
case for other countries like Germany
but in the US there's a lot of slave
labor that takes place outside of the
United States yeah the Congo would be a
great example of that and my whole point
is more regulation I think needs to be
accomplished in order for things like
that to not be allowed of U.S
corporations yeah so I mean it's really
not there there's on let me I'll give
you two answers
in what you're telling me there is a bit
of a contradiction in the sense that
you're sort of espousing different views
about your expectations of government
depending on which issue we're talking
about like for example you support LGBT
rights but you're against governments
regulating businesses businesses that
might discriminate against LGBT people
hold on I'm not saying you said that
Connor I'm just saying that's a way in
which there might be a contradiction but
let me zoom out to the bigger picture
in my view
saying that as a corporation once you've
reached a certain size there might be
additional regulations placed on you I
agree with that and I think that right
now that's a fundamentally left-wing
economic perspective and I don't claim
to be educated on this stuff but I was
trying to explain like you know I'm
still for small businesses being able to
do what they want but in a more
Progressive stance I don't think
corporations should be able to do what
they want considering and by
corporations you mean large corporations
right because small businesses might
also be a corporation yeah corporate
monopolies I think is what I'm really
trying to get at is a corporations
relatively left wing to me I mean it's
I'm not hearing anything definitively
right wing in there
um well again I I like capitalism I'm
not someone that thinks that capitalism
is inherently evil yeah just remember
social democracy which is the the
economic model of Denmark and Sweden and
other northern European countries it's a
form of capitalism it's well regulated
yeah there's like social democracy
there's social Democrats and then
there's Democratic socialists yeah
socialists who would want a capitalist
Society to become socialist inevitably
it would be Democratic socialists so I
guess in that sense yeah I would I'm for
social programs yeah no listen Connor
you're sounding uh you're sounding
pretty at least in 2023 for the United
States standard you're sounding sounding
at minimum Center left and uh always
good to hear how things are going
politically for you nice talking to you
David all right there goes Connor from
Jersey sounding less and less like a
republican every time we talk why don't
we go next to Smith from Phoenix Smith
from Phoenix welcome to the program uh
please unmute yourself what's on your
mind today
[Music]
only joining join in the
race later today officially and he's
doing it with fan Pharaoh the Elon Musk
uh I've been thinking about why Elon is
wanting to do this with the scientists
and what I'm thinking and let me know
what you think about this Elon wants to
do this to basically
incentivize Trump to come back on news
platform and basically have a Twitter
war between DeSantis and Trump on his
platform I'm not entirely convinced Elon
is doing this to say he's endorsing
DeSantis but to bring him on his
platform to
and essentially Cokes Trump back on the
platform when he hasn't so far
surprisingly yeah I don't think you're
wrong about that being a possible
motivation for musk I think there are
others as well including that he's
seeing this as a way to potentially be a
bigger player in the presidential
campaign and uh you know there's there's
personal ego reasons and different
things but this this is something a
couple people actually emailed me about
Smith which was the idea that this is
going to make this is if Trump does
nothing as far as Twitter goes this will
make Twitter even more of a pro de Santa
Safe Haven it'll make it overtly one and
Twitter has become very right-wing since
Elon Musk took it over you look at the
for you feed and it's just right-wing
nonsense so I think that Elon Musk May
indeed be making the calculation you're
making which is maybe this is how you
get Trump back on Twitter and Twitter
becomes the platform where this uh
Republican primary plays out which is
just great for Twitter which quite
frankly does doesn't seem to be doing
that well right now
I agree with that uh
to the to me Elon is under the guise of
free speeches really coaxing on
Republicans I'm not sure how that's
going to work for him long uh in the
long term but yeah I don't either you
know a lot of these the scientists
people don't like electric vehicles and
they don't like a lot of what Elon Musk
is up to and when you actually think
about it so I don't know you know
politics makes strange bedfellas but
let's give it a few weeks and then we'll
analyze it
all right Smith from Phoenix thank you
so much for the call appreciate it thank
you very much let's take a very quick
break and then we'll come back and hear
from some more folks so if you're
waiting to talk to me uh just hang on
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to Discord and hear from a few more
people davidpackman.com
Discord is the place to go let's go to
genio from Chester I guess it's a very
complicated thing or uh I don't know
which is the name and which is the
location Jenny welcome
hi David how are you doing well
awesome great to speak to you again
um I just hopped on so I didn't have a
question ready
um
uh what do you think are you a fan a fan
of
um Sean King the activist no I'm not
oh what are your reasons for that
I don't want to make this a whole thing
um listen I basically
uh I I'm trying to figure out how to do
this without like saying things that
aren't public my understanding is that
there's a sizable grift going on there
and it's never been my sort of activism
that I've seen him engage in and
honestly I didn't think he was active
anymore I haven't heard anyone mention
his name for years I I mean maybe he's
still doing stuff but I thought that he
had kind of Gone Gone silent some years
ago
oh okay
um yeah he's on Instagram and you know
uh I don't think he's as big as he was
but um yeah that was my question for
today thank you so much love love your
show all right there goes genio
hopefully that doesn't get me into any
trouble who the hell knows these days
anything can get you into trouble why
don't we go next to John from Salt Lake
City Utah the uh center of the uh Church
of Latter-day Saints John welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
yeah so I just have one question uh what
do you think of the recent news that
apparently some Russian partisans
invaded Uh Russian city of Belgrade you
didn't see that that could have been
like our special forces in there or
maybe encouraging them training them
something like that I have not heard of
that at all I'm going to have uh to to
research that
um I what when did this happen
this was like I think it was yesterday
or the day before jeez no I haven't seen
that yet and so the idea is that it may
not be what it actually appears to be
yeah so what I'm thinking is maybe they
got training from like NATO forces in
order to do something like that or like
they're like directly involved in a way
you get what I'm saying
um that's interesting so what I'm
reading is
it seems Russia has not invaded But
rather
uh belgarad the Russian border region
was attacked by an armed group Crossing
from Ukraine there's a couple sources
saying that Russia accused Ukraine of
being responsible Ukraine Ukraine denied
it and said the attackers were Russian
citizens from paramilitary groups that
oppose Putin it seems we really don't
know right now what the truth is that's
what I'm gathering John is from what the
pictures that I've seen it looks like it
could have been equipment that we
donated I saw a couple of Humvees in
there yet listen that's so speculative I
just don't know I would be cautious
about making it a definitive statements
right now you know I mean I don't want
to literally like pop on one bad wagon
the other I just want to like see a
little bit more details you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah I want to know the
truth of what happened from what I'm
seeing I'm looking at five sources and
they don't agree on what happened right
now
yeah all right thank you very much all
right I appreciate it yeah we're gonna
have to look more into that maybe by
next week we'll have uh more more
information but that's that's quite a
wild situation let's go to Brett from
Chicago Brett welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey Ava can you hear me yes I can
yeah yeah I'm glad to uh report from a
winning part of the country in a few
different ways I mean we just got most
Progressive mayor in history elected
here true and I'm also originally from
Minnesota and a lot of great things I
don't know if you've been hearing about
that a lot of it great things been
coming out of like the Minnesota
Legislature recently I heard I heard
some we covered one story uh yeah I mean
so you're feeling good about the part of
the country you're in it sounds like
yeah yeah honestly I'm a member of the
local um ydsa here you know the
Democratic socialists of America and we
were pretty excited we didn't endorse
Brandon Johnson directly because he's
not like a socialist but pretty heavily
uh I think he got support from our
sector a lot of the activity going out
and doing work on the ground canvassing
talking to people at polling stations
and that sort of thing so Brett as a Dem
as an actual Democratic Socialist
yourself I'm curious do you align with
the Socialist perspective of uh
socializing ownership of businesses like
is that something businesses should be
required to do by government
um I'm
I'm definitely on the
I guess you'd call it the more
conservative side of the democratic
socialists it's a pretty big tent party
as far as like current like practical uh
boots on the ground activism like what
we're at on what we are um advocating
for isn't like
you know is it isn't normally that uh
extreme like
turning all businesses into co-ops
immediately through an executive order I
mean a lot of people again in the
organization would disagree with me on
that yeah yeah no I'm just asking you
like what would be your biggest
socialist belief would you say
yeah I would say that like I would be in
favor of things as straight as Extreme
as probably like breaking up large
corporations uh making more things like
publicly
not you know publicly uh owned like re
like d private deprivatizing like
infrastructure things like that I mean
like start with like the big things
where it seems very reasonable that you
and I would probably agree on like
public transport or you know you know
things that like other countries
socialize and socialize well yeah and
then I would just probably keep moving
forward on that until it stops being
effective but so are you sure you're a
socialist that's interesting it's not I
mean there's your it sounds like you're
more of like a Social Democrat which is
a form of capitalism
yeah yeah I mean in the midterm it seems
to be that way but like I would like a
like having the means of production
being socialized being out like large
Industries being collectively owned that
seems like a good thing to me it's just
how we get there like social democracy
like I'm an electoralist I'm a you know
slow gradual movement so in the in the
short to medium term I do look
effectively like a a Social Democrat so
your view is sort of like that espoused
by Ian vausch the streamer where he says
in the immediate really socialist and
social Democrats probably would agree on
the same policies it's just that if they
were achieved then the Socialists would
want to go further yeah oh gosh I'm
getting out of here for agreeing with
Bosh so that's gonna be that's gonna be
great if this ever lies away because a
lot of people in the the DSA are not uh
not fans of his they're anti-vouch
that's interesting yeah there's a big
anti-vous movement probably a big anti
David packman movement as well oh
obviously listen there's no doubt
there's an anti-david packman movement
among the Socialists that's that's
without a doubt but uh yeah before you
before you let me go David I've gotta I
I should like represent that I am more
left in a way and actually ask you a a
somewhat difficult question or at least
it might it might not be difficult okay
please uh because you get a lot of
criticism from the left specifically on
uh your coverage of South America and
like Latin American politics I'm sure no
I mean I only I know years ago something
about Bolivia but I didn't know that
that was like an ongoing thing oh okay
so maybe you're not okay so there are
like a few things it's not like massive
but uh like I wonder if you have any
updates on that one story you covered
because you got some heat from that in
my circles anyway when you covered uh I
believe it was an Argentina there was an
assassination attempt and the way you
presented it was you were like very
suspicious of it and like it's kind of
suggesting that it may have been
something like a false flag or you know
like that it wasn't a real assassination
attempt and this was pretty like
immediate after the uh oh no I think I I
mean that was a while ago I don't know
if I didn't speak clearly or if maybe
you're misremembering it or I am but it
was more the idea that these that sort
of hijinks is the stuff I wouldn't put
past Christina but I was very very clear
that it was not uh something I was
asserting took place or I mean I was
super clear that it's merely speculative
and that there are people wondering
about it but that it was such an you
know uh offhanded thing I wasn't putting
a lot of stock in it I wasn't trying to
convince anyone of that I mean no it was
just it was just a you know it's just
casual conversation
oh okay okay fair enough yeah some
people get uh pretty antsy about like
that sort of speculation with you know
because people are a fan because they're
like the what the slightly more left
party and yeah country like Center left
I mean listen I'll be honest what I can
tell you is I think Christine is
completely out of her mind I mean cuckoo
for Coco Puffs I don't know if you've
been following her recently but seems
completely disconnected from reality but
that's probably a story for another day
uh okay sure enough well thank you much
very much for having me on David all
right Brett from Chicago worried about
uh worried about agreeing with Ian
vausch uh hopefully he doesn't get in
trouble why don't we speak next just
because we're doing it and we have time
let's speak to Michael from New Jersey
Michael from New Jersey welcome to the
David pakman show what's on your mind
today
Michael from New Jersey please accept my
invitation to appear on my program
and last chance for Michael from New
Jersey
all right well that's too bad really
seem to want to get on why don't we go
next to I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly is it sa'en from Israel cyan
uh it's Sean thanks for having me oh
it's Sean wow I've never seen Sean
spelled though uh yeah my mom she's uh
she's Irish so that's how this spell
love it all right well what's going on
uh I'm from uh well from Israel
it's a touchy subject right now but so
your mom is an Irish Jewish person
uh no she's Catholic but near my dad or
my mom's uh are religious I mean I grew
on the kibbutz are you familiar with it
of course yeah but so hold on a second
neither of your parents is Jewish but
you were brought up no no my dad is uh
Safari Jewish okay
and my mom she's a Catholic Irish but
yeah no I had I had never heard of
non-people with no Jewish parents
growing up on kibbutzim that's but you
said your dad is Jewish got it yeah I
mean well she also volunteered at the
kibauts so that's how they met but uh so
yeah I would
um other than that I thought maybe
um you know if if there's a such thing
because I know there's a commune in the
U.S and it's usually it happens this bad
stigma because most of the time in U.S
it's like a four bad reasons but I
thought you know like but the keyboards
it's like one of the like great example
that actually worked for us really well
actually you know like
if it gets some Implement some elements
of that and kind of like or or prove it
in some ways because
are interesting and they're often used
as case studies for look this is an
example of a pseudosocialized commune
type community that really works well I
think there are a couple of things Sean
that are often said in response to that
one is the do you know like what's the
largest kibbutz how many people are part
of the largest kibbutz
um not much to be honest I didn't really
follow up I mean I know my kibbutz
doesn't do well these days because they
did some bad decisions the last parts of
their lands or something but well I
guess what I'm getting at is the the two
most common uh rebuttals to the idea of
the kibbutz is proof of communal
organization is one kibutsima relatively
small often 150 or fewer people and and
even with the bigger ones which maybe
are in the 500s I think that you're
really getting to the upper reaches of
when that sort of organization makes
sense and so a lot of times people say
sure do it with 15 000 people and you'll
see it no longer make sense which of
course isn't really the point of the
kibbutz that's one thing that's that's
often said
um the other thing that's often said is
you know it's a bit of a cop-out to look
at the kibbutz as the proof of the
commune living because it doesn't stand
on its own it exists within the state of
of Israel and all of the benefits and
infrastructure that the state of Israel
provides so it's not really a good
example of self-sufficiency the counter
to that counter would be actually a lot
of these kibbutzim are quite
self-sufficient so it's it's a it's a
conversation that takes place I think
both sides have interesting perspectives
yeah um
do like exact same fruit I mean like
well what's it sound like uh like a new
thing it's it's it's just a sort of like
like yeah it's like a sort of modern
version I guess of a commune it's not
new it's not like uh it's really
mentioned but
um I thought like I don't know maybe we
could take some elements of it or or
improve it in some ways you don't need
to I agree I mean listen there's been a
lot written about some of the great
things uh that that you see at kibbutzim
including the sort of community child
rearing that takes place where people
watch out and participate watch out for
and and help to raise all children in
the community
um the the safety you there's a lot of
things I think that are that are
interesting regardless of your views on
Socialism or capitalism or whatever I
mean I guess that's why I'm more I guess
more in the socialism Vibe I mean
because I'm more that's I'm more
familiar with it that makes sense yeah
and I mean I was growing was not
religious like to sell hams all that
all right and uh remember every time you
swear our producer has to bleep it so
let's try not to uh not to do that sorry
Sean listen it all sounds incredible I
really do appreciate you calling in
today
all right have a nice day all right
there goes Sean from Israel we almost
squeaked through today with no bleeps
but Sean got us he really did all right
everybody that's gonna do it for today
we will take calls again and I hope you
are one of the next people I speak to
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right we're going to look at what
many of you wrote in over the last week
we're going to start with something that
is scary too much is it too much to call
this scary this is where we are right
now
Ray Wright commented on YouTube
I as well as every other Maga fan will
never vote for anyone else but for the
true president Donald Trump
he could be behind bars and we will
still vote for him Trump is the only one
that we can trust right now
this is a call
we know that this is a cult we've spoken
to cult experts we've spoken to
conspiracy experts we've spoken about
brainwashing we've put every expert
looks this up and down and says yes this
is a cult
but we also have to deal with the
political reality on the ground and so
when we see oh Tim Scott announced that
he's running
Tim Scott is somehow going to win a
Republican primary over Trump give me a
break
Ron DeSantis is trying to be like Trump
but be different than Trump
one aspect of why these guys don't
really have a shot
is because of them
the other aspect of why they don't have
a shot is because of people like Ray
Wright
Trump has assembled a cult of
personality around him that is unlike
listen it's I never like to say we've
never seen it in history no there are
over cult leaders and they have cult
followers that's not new
but in the modern American political era
there has never been a cult around an
elected official
in the United States the way we see
around Donald Trump so when Ray Wright
says this stuff the true president is
Trump he could be behind bars and I'll
vote for him
believe them
because they're telling us the truth and
the question for us is how do we ensure
that Trump doesn't get another four
years the answer is quite simple
but making it happen
is another question let's look at some
other uh messages that came in the teen
gunsmith said Oh Boy on YouTube Don't
ban books in schools except for heavy
violence or sexual items like
genderqueer for example
now every time I see stuff like this I'm
of two minds on the one hand
the Bible has to be banned based on this
right I mean there's there's no way to
follow this guideline heavy violence and
sexual items
you you must ban the Bible from school
if you actually are going to be serious
about that but then I'm also reminded
that when you look at what materials
have been banned from schools it's often
just a completely unremarkable novel The
coming to age novel where the main
character or the author happened to be
LGBT
ban it
okay and so yes they're Hypocrites
because the Bible is fine but also their
standards are extraordinarily pathetic
and it shows such a lack of tolerance
for anything other than what they I
guess now pretend school kids need which
is stories by heterosexual writers about
how great America is that that seems to
be the epitome of what they want
um they truly can't handle any other
ideas any other identities any other
sort of content they are the very
snowflakes they claim that the left
actually is caddy lover says name one
law that has been passed that censors
that's not the right version of sensors
that censors the thing you are claiming
if you are referring to limiting
teachers from discussing topics like
gender
sexual orientation or the making up of
multiple pronouns with children in one
AR second or third grade
I would ask how are you okay with it
I don't even know what this person is
asking
I I just it
it's it's clear they don't like the
left-wing perspective and they favor the
don't say Gable
but what I really need people to
understand is
when they talk about parents rights and
being heard at school-born meetings and
blah blah all this different stuff
this is the type of commentary they want
to hear at school board meetings they
want to turn the school board meeting
into a veritable circus Sideshow with
stuff like this
and that's exactly what they did during
the pandemic ERA with the masks and at
other times
and if they were to be in control
that's who would be in charge that
should scare every single one of us a
Florida son says say what you want about
his personality him being DeSantis
Florida has one of the best economies in
the U.S we're below average for Crime
both violent and property crime he
doesn't govern with his personality he's
not out to be a reality TV star he knows
how to get the job done that is what
should be important a beautiful story
but it is only a story as I told you
before Florida doesn't have one of the
best economies in the U.S it's right
around 25th it's average you take any
state in the country there's a 50 50
shot that it has a better versus worse
economy than Florida Florida's economy
is totally middle of the road
Florida's crime rate totally middle of
the road it's not particularly good it's
not particularly bad Access to Health
Care in Florida very mediocre
infrastructure in Florida similarly
middle of the road and so the story of
this Florida success that DeSantis is
touring the country talking about if
it's examined even at all
it immediately becomes clear
Florida is right in the middle not a
particularly successful State not a
particularly unsuccessful State and then
the question becomes whether we think
that that record is worthy of a
presidential candidate Republicans will
have to answer that question first they
can decide are we impressed by the
Florida record of DeSantis enough to
make him the nominee instead of Donald
Trump
non-quack rodent
and said let me ask a question
should business owners be able to choose
whether or not they require masks but
not be completely controlled by the
state if they don't wish to bake a cake
for a gay wedding well it's a beautiful
uh analogy except that it is completely
nonsensical when in the United States we
talked about protected classes of people
in some states
LGBT identity gender identity sexual
orientation is a protected class
if indeed LGBT is a protected class then
discriminating against someone on that
basis would be against the law whereas
saying we have a policy here where
you've got to wear shoes or you've got
to wear a mask or whatever would be a
completely different category now I'm
not an unreasonable person if what
individuals are saying is there should
be no protected classes and everybody
should be allowed to do whatever they
want and say we don't want black people
in this store we don't allow Jewish
customers here or whatever if that's the
world that you want to to see well take
that position or take the position that
is on the opposite of that but don't
make this false analogy because we have
something called protected classes you
might not like that but it is the
reality and thus it makes the mask
versus gay wedding cake question a
completely irrelevant question under the
law now if you want the law changed by
all means go and advocate for that
Lynette posted on Facebook
if DeSantis was smart he would wait and
run in 2028 but he's too greedy and
narcissistic to play the long game and
we all know that he's not too smart I've
talked about this before on the one hand
I don't see a path for DeSantis to get
to 50 support in the Republican primary
which he needs to be the nominee so one
view would be
dude Trump's already got 55 60 percent
you can't win just wait it out run in
2028. the Counterpoint to that and I
understand this is most people most
Governors aren't polling 20 in the
Republican primary it's true most
Senators aren't pulling 20 in the
Republican primary so if you're Ron
DeSantis it could be difficult to look
at that polling and say 20 before I even
announce
I'm gonna wait four years
it's very difficult to do that it's sort
of like in poker when you flopped High
pair and you know you should probably
fold but you just can't quite get away
from it you want to see it through and
see how you do even if it cripples your
ability to run again in the future
um I think Lynette makes a good point
and I also see why DeSantis would not be
motivated by that
okay a bunch of commentary about the
Christopher key urine drinking interview
Baron Steuben posted this was an
incredibly insightful interview into how
trauma can affect the cognition of
otherwise reasonable individuals I
appreciate David's thoughtful handling
of this interview and not allowing it to
descend into a farce despite the
outrageous statements made by
Christopher it's important to understand
why these individuals think like this in
order to treat and prevent such
delusions agree 100
we really learned a lot about the sad
reality
of how Christopher key ended up
allegedly drinking and injecting urine I
will mention
I don't know that he was really drinking
urine I don't know that he really
injects urine and people wrote to me and
said do we really have proof that he's
actually drinking urine and not apple
juice and the answer is we really don't
we're taking him at his word
not necessarily the type of guy you want
to take at his word but okay a worker
bee from Wisconsin says I wish the media
would report gun injuries over deaths to
get a better picture of the Damage Done
by mass shootings and this is an
interesting point which says for example
the 2017 Las Vegas shooting had 60
deaths but over 400 gunshot injuries
with an additional 450 injuries from
fleeing danger how many of those 400
wounded victims are permanently disabled
or worse now it would be a nice uh it
would be nice to turn the narrative away
from Strictly mortality and include
Serious injury as well just reporting
death seems to minimize the Carnage for
the benefit of the gun lobby I believe
that this is a good point and I'm going
to make an effort to say killed
and injured as well we don't always have
completely accurate data on that but I
think that that is a good point and we
shouldn't understate I mean you know if
six people die but 80 are also in
hospitals some in critical condition
some serious Etc that is a hundred
percent part of the Damage Done by these
Mass Shooters and we shouldn't ignore
that so I'll try to do a better job
email info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say we will have a
fantastic bonus show for you today we
are off Monday Memorial day but
it is the day of our huge membership
special if you are interested in
becoming a member if you might want to
become a member and get all of the great
member benefits we offer
this Monday Memorial day we'll be
sending out an email in the morning
maybe 10 a.m seems like a good time
Eastern and it'll contain a coupon code
and instructions for signing up for a
membership at a comical discount comical
discount to be notified get on my
mailing list at davidpackman.com
thank you